[Music]
so
i run to the morning
as the nightmares change to form me
should i make a stand
i walk in the shadows cause i'm scared
of what the light shows is the power in
these hands
i feel like a wasted soul
a hologram of skin problems this is
[Music]
is
the fear in the climbing sometimes the
voices will be blinding
but they'll never have your fault
to ride their heads
it puts the flesh back to your bones
this is the choice
[Music]
is
whatever happens happens
[Music]
i'm letting go
give me time
[Music]
just give me time to wake up
hey thank you all so much for checking
out this wonderful flow session i want
to do a real quick thank you to ultra
poi for sponsoring this video and giving
me a reason to get out into dc and play
around with my poi every month
uh you can get a set of those orb poi
pros that i was using in this video if
you head on over to ultrapoi.com and use
the promo code drexfactor with a zero
instead of an o at checkout that gets
you a discount and it helps out the
channel so everybody wins uh thank you
once again to ultra poi for sponsoring
this video
um also uh big thanks to the friends of
the channel that is big thanks to uh
dark monk fire mecca uh flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible uh you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
work that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this here video and
special thank you to the non-business
friends of the channel that is uh johnny
howard les muchinski and becca bakunen
thank you all so very much for your
support for me and my mission and
finally uh this video would not be
possible were it not for the kind
support of all of these nice people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your support if you
out there watching are not currently
supporting you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
you can do that either at the link down
in the description or the card that just
popped up if you're watching on youtube
and you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards there such as getting
your own personal
lessons sent to your inbox every single
week that is available only to patreon
subscribers go check that out please and
thank you
if you'd like to check out some of the
other flow sessions i've done i'll go
ahead and leave links to them down in
the description a little playlist if you
will as well as a link up here on screen
if you're watching on youtube uh the
youtube algorithm also thinks that
you'll probably like this top video here
based upon your past viewing habits so
you might want to check that out as well
um thank you all so much for watching
and make sure that you get outside and
flow today and i'll see you with a new
video on monday
peace